five islands of mozambique's buzzer ruto
archipelago are part of the National
Park stretching more than 1,400 square
kilometers marine biologist and Draya
Marshall has been doing research here
for 13 years the nutrient-rich waters
are a breeding ground for several large
marine mammal and fish such as the manta
ray and all my travels around the world
I've never encountered a location where
both species of manta rays live so this
makes it such a critical habitat for
mattress and this is one of the reasons
why I've dedicated my life to doing
research in southern mozambique
unfortunately over the last 10 years we
lost about eighty eight percent of the
population and that's mainly due to gill
net fishing and also poaching of the
animals it's up to park rangers to make
sure the protected areas are safe and
secure Tomaj manasa supervises 23
Rangers for the national park he says he
needs more to cover their many jobs and
patrolling duties as Canada for the
communities outside the National Park
had no spaces where the fish can
reproduce fish stocks decline the
pressure grows that leads to ever
greater conflict with the fishermen from
the mainland which that they even
encroach on the totally protected areas
to go fishing in [ __ ] back nice Irish
dude brother sample pal for the beauty
for the Heritage what alternative
livelihoods do the fishermen have well
tourism is one Andrea Marshall and her
team have invited 10 Park Rangers and
their new boss to take part in training
it's the first time they've worked so
closely together on a map they mark
where they've seen certain animal
species and compare the sightings with
the researchers data amore thing for
this course is very important if we
manage to work together well on the
first phase will be able to negotiate a
second and the third will learn how to
go diving ourselves and show the
tourists the fish another
ma'am many of them have to learn to swim
first the intensive course lasts five
days it's not unusual that the local
people don't know how to swim but many
have always wanted to it will help them
protect the marine life and know the
reefs better Mozambique is is is making
sort sort of somewhere in the vicinity
of seven to eight million dollars a year
off Monterey diving tourism and I feel
that you know that definitely can be an
incentive you know for government to say
listen this animal is worth a lot more
alive than it is dead we don't really
have much time to be able to you know
rebuild those numbers before they're
regionally extinct here but Mozambique
has yet to place the manta ray on its
list of protected species the biologist
says that would be a big step